I think this is just my opinion that a
lot of times we would be helped as women
if men were a little more honest with us
and usually if we're single by a certain
age there's there's a reason yeah
because like men will find like an eight
or higher that's fit feminine friendly
mental font they'll like sniff them up
they'll she'll go to the grocery store
and get like you yeah I mean you can all
think a girl right and I think a lot of
times we live in delusion past a certain
age because nobody will be honest with
us because they're trying to protect our
feelings no I love a lot of that is a
lot of things that do happen that does
happen often yeah not all the time yeah
sorry to his sister anyways anyways uh
Christine what do you think I mean two
things come to mind for me really I mean
the answer everyone's pretty much given
as to single by choice is that the
options aren't available well that's not
really by choice then is it because if
the option was available then you
wouldn't be single and the second thing
is I think you attract what you are so
if the options aren't available I do
think that that's an indication that you
perhaps are shooting too high and you're
not acknowledging where you are and what
you bring to the table because I'm a
very firm believer that we always
attract what we are in life and if the
options available to you are not what
you like
that's not the world's problem I think
that's your problem
what are you this single by choice what
do you think
I would say it depends on the
environment as well because for my
example I've taken myself as an example
like for example I'm keeping myself for
marriage and I'm gonna be single for a
long time because in this generation sex
is everything are you a virgin yeah oh
you are yeah I am okay and so how I'm
just shocked no no one is in this day
and age
um and so you feel like that's kept you
single yes okay that yeah it's just that
if there's nothing else
yeah there's not no room for improvement
anywhere of course yeah I have to
improve on certain things for myself but
personally I think that's one of the
main things that will like make me
single okay yeah even if that's the
point I was making is that your answer
is that it's the environment and it's
not you and I think I'm not saying I
know anything about you right I don't
however I do think it's our own
responsibility to take accountability
for our own circumstances so if you
don't like the circumstances you're in
which I don't know if you do I'm just
saying hypothetically if you don't like
the circumstances you're in
I don't think blaming the environment is
a way to change that I think in fact
blaming yourself and perhaps recognizing
in yourself maybe I'm not doing all the
things I could be to attract what I want
I think that's a better route to
actually getting what you want than
saying oh it's because of this reason
and that reason and oh our paths aren't
aligned I I don't I personally don't
believe in that and I think if you want
something in life the way to get it is
by changing yourself it doesn't depend
on anything else around you I understand
I'm not blaming the society or anything
like I'm very happy to be single to be
honest like it's not something that is
not a priority for me to like find a
husband and get married is I would love
to get married like I wouldn't mind
getting married like young but it's not
a priority for me I'd rather like work
on myself do what I want to do and and I
know at the same time that I don't
necessarily project that like you would
never think that I'm you know like
vision and stuff so I know maybe I do
like I don't track my type
well yeah it's not video priority for me
to be honest I feel like if I meet
someone and the person understand my
point of view but doesn't that explain
your whole situation you've just said
that it's not a priority and that's why
you're single yeah
the fact that you've just said that you
put um you know you said like finding
yourself first and yeah right so that's
that's you putting yourself at the top
and then putting marriage and kids if
you want children second because if you
put them at the top chances are you you
probably at least be on route to having
that already
so what do you think I should do to be
on top to find the house oh I I don't
know it's this what you want in life if
I'm saying if what you want in life is
to find yourself and do whatever first
and chances are that's what's gonna
happen what I'm also highlighting is
that if that then does happen well you
might then get that and then decide well
I want the marriage and kids and
everything but by that time that happens
you might have already shortened your
chances because of what we were saying
earlier about what men generally is a
rule find attractive in a woman
obviously you have the fact that you're
a virgin massively on your side but
that you know your Youth and your
fertility by the time you found yourself
chances are that's not going to be as
Prime as it could be I don't think I
should be like running for that like I
should have been running for a man like
looking for that because I need that
it's not like for me we all need a man
I'm sorry I don't know if you agree with
that but for me we all need a man but
that doesn't stop me from living my life
and I feel like me and the right person
will come at the perfect time I
shouldn't like wait or like be like okay
now I'm 24 like I'm 23. so so I have I
have a stat for you they're predicting
that in our age demographic half of us
are going to be single and childless
never have children
damn so the data isn't backing up what
you're saying that most women it's just
going to happen for and that we have to
do nothing to get the men that we want
because that's essentially what you're
saying you're saying I should work on
myself and you're like there's no what
we can do for them it's always what can
we do for ourselves I definitely I
definitely believe that you do attract
out you said your circumstances and the
things that you're ready for and the
things that you admit and put out there
are things that will be attracted to you
at some point in time because that's
what you're going after so that has a
big part to play with a lot of it so a
lot of the single women who say that I'm
happy with being not single is and and
putting it as a second thing on their
list that would obviously hinder the
chances of being in a relationship
because I'm saying because the energy
ain't even aligning for that to happen
yeah I'm saying so that is an agreeance
to what you said earlier but I agree but
what she's saying as well is you have
cultural factors as well that make it
for a woman to be difficult to go for a
man like from my culture we're gonna
wait for the money come for you so even
it's going to depend on the environment
that's where I agree with you it's going
to depend on the environment I'm living
in for me to alert right but the best
but the best women have been coming for
them all the time exactly you know I I
have a friend um I'd probably rate her
like eight nine and no matter where she
goes it's like
the the yeah she got married young oh my
God yeah she was because she she was you
know she was the ideal right like you
know so what's the idea
um fit so I would say look up your BMI
and if you're not your BMI then lose
weight yeah I mean it all starts there
right if you're not you can't you can't
say you carry if you're overweight you
can't say you care what men want because
that's the first thing they look for is
is weight
um I'd say like femininity so you know
um I I think especially Christian guys
want a woman that's going to obey them
and serve them and I think yeah and a
lot of women in the church really they
they don't do that they preach this like
Mutual submission thing the like which
which isn't even true it's not biblical
it's propaganda they put in the church
to basically leave the women single so
they can just donate for a lifetime it's
really it's really sad if you look into
the roots of it
um yeah I mean fit feminine friendly I'd
say it starts there you know Kevin
Samuels right yeah so what feminine in
front of XXX yeah I mean Kevin Samuels
was goaded for a reason right
um yeah and so I actually I don't think
there's a such thing as single by choice
I think it just means I think it's like
women we create these words that don't
mean anything yeah and to like to like
whenever something bad happens to us we
just seem to make up words to make it
like sound nicer so when the truth is
right when we're single The Men We want
don't want us right it's it's we don't
like the way I don't agree I'm gonna I
have a whiteboard for this real reason
yeah let's go
so
can we turn on oh [__] can we turn on
this one yeah okay it's not so this is
my thought our our modern women really
single by choice so we have
now this is the this is the I'm gonna
put some nice hair
yeah this is the Modern Woman a nice
modern woman right now she usually has
Instagram does anyone hear not of
Instagram
no no okay everybody's got an Instagram
now she's also goes you know do you who
goes out to eat here or anyone all right
so she also goes to get food let me
should I I'm just going to draw a plate
I know people are gonna
I can't draw okay so she goes and so
maybe she'll go to the grocery store
this is like a cart you know
okay please please bear with me and then
she might she might go to the gym which
is here's the gym there's a door
okay so she goes to all of these nice
places right and you know then the
Modern Woman has about like 50 guys
messaging her on Instagram then another
guy might go it like you know talk to
her at a restaurant who's here has been
approached on Instagram who's gotten a
message yeah everybody okay who here has
gotten a message on on at dinner yeah
okay who's gotten approached at the gym
right okay so the Modern Woman is really
getting approached everywhere now
there's different types of guys
approaching right so we have Bob Joe
now these three guys are approaching
everywhere now this is um we're gonna
call him
um option A we're gonna actually know
I'm gonna make him option C
so C B A that's the quality now a man is
the best right now hey man
if he approached the Modern Woman she
would say yes she's be excited right but
he wants
the traditional hottie
what you want me do you do you think you
appear to be a traditional woman
yes I don't think so I am no you are but
you don't appear
yeah okay
um I I would say you're not a
traditional Woman based on your mindset
now this is now I'm going to tell you
why okay okay I'm gonna tell you what I
think that traditional Women Believe by
and large the family comes first and
they live their life this way
traditional women really are married
before the age of 25 I don't claim it's
me okay I just say the truth these are
we gotta you know as women we gotta
admit like who is the best we gotta say
who is the ideal right just like men can
say LeBron James is the ideal basketball
player I think as women we should come
together and say that chick that's the
ideal woman right and the ideal woman
puts Family First in her primary
reproductive years so they're usually
married before 25 and they typically
um believe in obeying and serving a Man
based on the words you said which is
that you wanted to focus on yourself
that puts me above the family and that
puts you in the modern category no well
you know um because I feel like I don't
know if you can hear me yeah I feel like
for the family one even if you're not
married into 25 I mean
even if you're a rent a rotated family
that's just settling
well this is that's a very modern
mindset now traditional women are happy
and grateful to have a man but modern
women modern women think they're
settling when typically the man is above
them now I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
guys I'm gonna tell you why men nowadays
are better than women to go back to what
you said I believe there is such thing
as a modern traditional woman I think
there's that's a new word that women
made up because they don't like the way
it sounds
yes yes I think that no no
myself as that yeah which one because I
put family first I had a child very
early so indeed focus on my child first
okay before but did you did you stay
with the dad no okay
no no now you're here single mothers
what ended yeah it was not a traditional
man okay no no no no no like what who
did you break up with him yeah okay see
that was my feelings above my family it
was my son's feeling no no no how old
was your son okay so the two-year-old
broke up your marriage it did
no I think that like you don't like the
way it sounds right okay how how was he
not traditional it was a traditional
because first of all I was a provider
okay I was the one going to school and
provide for the family okay what did he
do what did he do okay why why did you
pick a guy that does not have a job we
were young that's what I'm saying okay
so again again let me go back to Modern
women pick men without jobs because
that's what they qualified
okay sorry I mean I don't think this
shouldn't be crazy it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be
how else would you okay let's let's
let's break this down how else would you
know what you qualify for at least I
didn't know I was 18 years old okay and
at 18 years old you know there's women
that marry rich men of course and you
married a broke man I was I was around
what I knew so so the offers okay let me
let me let me break this down let's go
back to it so these were the offers that
were coming to you and it was broke men
yeah now some 18 year olds
some 18 year olds I know 18 year olds
right that get marriage offers from
Richmond yeah so the only common
denominator here is that you are
a modern woman it's okay
I did it so now now here's the thing
traditional women take accountability
modern women no I can say based on this
conversation I fully take accountability
but at the end of the day okay of course
there isn't the environment as well that
you grew up in okay let's let's talk
about the environment
traditional women so so there are
traditional women right that grow up
that start off they grow up in a bad
environment right but they seek out
wives and don't get pregnant out of
wedlock and don't make any of those
stupid choices no offense but they don't
marry the broke men or have kids with
the bro I I think maybe you should just
say the marriage because you like you
were trying to defend well we weren't
married and I'm like is this this is
worse so that's like that's like more
mom